oh I saw the movie infinite oh
the infinite I
I'm probably thinking what's that movie
and the reason why you're thinking it is
the same reason why I'm talking about it
in this Cadence because it's so bad and
that means no one saw it it's so bad
what's the movie well it's Mark Wahlberg
and the guy from 12 Years a Slave and
some chick
saw it wow it's bad yo it's got 16 on
Rotten Tomatoes and people will be like
well was that the audience score of the
credit score and to that I'd say who
gives a [ __ ]
it was so bad dude I couldn't even
believe it Mark Wahlberg is first of all
Mark Wahlberg is a fine actor and I will
tell you this there have been movies
where he's been great
great actually
and there has been movies where he's
been bad and that's fine
those are my favorite kind of actors as
a matter of fact because it means What
They're Taking Chances or they're bad
and they have good directors either way
I don't care
so I'm watching this movie and I know
Mark Wahlberg is capable of being a
really great actor but what he's not
capable of doing is being a really good
voice over actor dude they have voice
over in the movie and he's just like
they say that when you want to be live
when you die you go to a place and they
say that actually what happens and
everything was and they say that
and some people and they're called the
nihilists and the other people are
called the people that want to live
they're the Believers and then the
Believers and the nihilists and when you
die you don't just die and you're just
like oh you as Morgan Freeman
I don't even give a [ __ ] have Morgan
Freeman still be that character just
don't have Mark Wahlberg do the voice
over too
Morgan Freeman could pop on and be like
hi just so you know I'm still the Morgan
Freeman character but we couldn't have
Mark Wahlberg do this because it's so
[ __ ] weird when he does voiceovers
watch this and then Mark Wahlberg will
come on and be like because there's
nihilists and there's also Believers and
then Morgan Freeman would be like
see
[Laughter]
dude oh it's bad
it's so bad dude and Antonio Fuqua
whatever the [ __ ] his name is dude
Anthony fuckwa is [ __ ] directed it
and he did Training Day
Macho Man ready
dude I just realized it's like Macho Man
Randy Savage dude
in the the scene in the bathroom where
they're holding the guns on [ __ ]
Ethan Hawke
get the guy [ __ ] he comes in with a
shotgun it's Macho Man Randy Savage
it's not even the Mexican guy and a
[ __ ] wife beater it's Macho Man Randy
Savage with the [ __ ] bandanas around
his biceps for some reason why was that
a thing ah whoa you get your [ __ ] pushed
in
so how much is [ __ ] what's his name
uh Macho Man Randy Savage gonna have a
clip that goes Super viral the next few
months and it's gonna be see and uh
how much is Macho Man Randy Savage gonna
have a clip that goes viral in a few
months and the [ __ ] the top of it's
gonna be like uh Macho Man Randy Savage
knew all along and it's gonna be some
for the 90s that he's gonna say
something about [ __ ] current times
I don't need any of you guys I'm having
a blast dude I [ __ ] love it man so
anyway I watched infinite and holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] 16 on Rotten Tomatoes
whether it's the critics or whether it's
the audience doesn't matter how did it
get 16 should have had less how I'll
tell you right now Chinese people in
China watching it that is the only kind
of person who would like that movie and
I don't mean it to be racist I just mean
shit's different over there and they
like [ __ ] cars blasting into outer
space and [ __ ] that's why f [ __ ] 10
or faster than Furious the most fast
furious scene movie they blast the car
into outer space and Chinese people were
just like in China Chinese got moved
here they realize that's bad
so I'm watching this [ __ ] movie into
Infinite and holy [ __ ] Mark Wahlberg
should never do voice overacting and he
knows it but he did it and I hope he
made a [ __ ] pretty penny off this
[ __ ] and they got that another guy
[ __ ] chip wall tinnedu in it
and then they got some chick I love when
they get the mo like a really famous
dude in a movie this is when you know a
movie's gonna be bad I will take it
right now
you get
an A-list actor in as the lead and then
as the second lead you get a guy that
nobody knows their name but they know
their face okay like the chin Adele
chitwell guy or whatever the [ __ ] the
guy was in 12 years of sleep but that's
not all
then to to make sure that it's a box
office disaster
you get for the third lead some check
right like not anadarmas not [ __ ]
even Selena Gomez not [ __ ] uh what's
her name Salma Hayek only meaning
Latinas but [ __ ] someone who's
literally some chick and you're like who
the [ __ ] is this and then you Google it
and she was in like [ __ ] season two
of the tutors
and you're like oh she's British
bro this movie is so funny it's one of
those movies where they're just like two
people like meet each other and already
they're just like Off to the Races in in
like they're like in the eighth year of
their relationship where they just say
stuff like
you know what I always thought was funny
and you're just like what you just met
this [ __ ]
and there's definitely that line I don't
know if there is or not because I wasn't
paying attention all the time but when
they say [ __ ] like you're either the
smartest guy I've ever met or the
craziest son of a [ __ ] that has ever
lived and then the next guy's like both
so you must be a nihilist
bro this movie is such a rip of the
Matrix and I don't like saying that dude
because every movie is a rip from
everything and it doesn't matter and
dude get that money [ __ ] repurpose
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] like people are
like oh dude this movie's [ __ ] great
it reinvented the wheel no it didn't
dude infinite is the second worst movie
of all time second to the new Matrix
here's why because
it well it basically tries to be the
Matrix and in a horrible way dude they
have the [ __ ] other guy who's the
black guy in it and Mark Wahlberg is
this guy who doesn't know who he is and
they're trying to tell him he's the guy
to save the [ __ ] world and Mark
Wahlberg's like no I'm not and then
there's like a [ __ ] check that's the
Trinity girl who kicks ass and then he
has to practice [ __ ] martial arts in
this thing with a guy that doesn't like
him for some reason or doesn't believe
that he's the one just right off the bat
that's one of my favorite things that
movie is the like a guy the lead will
meet another guy with a beard and he'll
be like I don't know I just don't like
him just because he's a beard
and that guy always dies
and at the end right before he dies he's
like I actually like you
anyway man this movie dude he [ __ ]
takes a motorcycle oh let me just
explain this [ __ ] before I get into it I
know I'm a heavy on the [ __ ] infinite
talk because four of you have seen it
but dude
basically everyone keeps
no there's a few people in the world
that have been destined to reincarnate
they don't die they die but their soul
goes to another body and they just keep
going the only way to kill them is to
use this gun with these Special bullets
that the [ __ ] 12 Years a Slave guy
has and he wants to kill all the
infinites because he is an infinite and
he hates being an infinite and nobody
should be an infinite because you just
have to be reborn and you remember all
your past lives and it's [ __ ] shitty
and so there's an egg that they have to
get that will destroy all of humanity
and the world and it will ruin
everyone's life because there won't be
life on Earth anymore and all the
infinites will die okay now he's trying
to get this egg for this to happen
because he doesn't want this infinite
[ __ ] to work anymore and as he's
fighting everybody when he comes across
an infinite he tries to shoot him with
these bullets and what happens at the
end is Mark Wahlberg wins obviously by
shooting the [ __ ] 12 Years a Slave
guy with that special bullet and he dies
and you're like oh good now he saved
wait a minute why didn't the [ __ ] 12
years ago a slave guy just shoot himself
he would have put himself out of the
misery
the whole movie falls apart
just kill you guy
at the end me and the [ __ ] dude I was
watching my buddy we go oh what the [ __ ]
and Mark Wahlberg's like guess he was a
nihilist
dude there's one scene where they sh he
shoots his bullet in the back of Mark
Wahlberg's head and Mark Wahlberg turns
around and says I'm disappointed in you
you knew I had a metal plate in my head
from my car accident and pulls the
bullet out hey a battle Play Can't Stop
a [ __ ] bullet
foreign
the screenwriters are like I mean what
the [ __ ] dude
the screenwriter is just like uh metal
plate they go like this metal plate and
then they go
I just put it in
you got to check this movie out dude
when you thought life was over
but there's more lives to live if you're
an infinite
there are nihilists
there are believers
at War
M I really don't think I'm the guy
you're the guy
Mark Wahlberg and the guy from 12 Years
a Slave and some chick in
prone infinite
[Music]
a movie that they tried to bury by
streaming it by having it come out
streaming during covid
so they couldn't actually so they could
hide behind the fact that it bombed
[Music]
that it bomb or did it was it covered
though
[Music]
gained the system
[Music]
[Music]